in recent years some people have peddled
an insane conspiracy theory called the
Great replacement which is the notion
that our political Elite has for decades
intentionally wielded our nation's
immigration policy to replace the
American people with foreigners the sort
of people who peddle this Theory
according to the liberal media are
lunatics and racists and Nazis and now
apparently Chuck Schumer now more than
ever were short of workers
uh we have a population that is not
reproducing it on its own with the same
level that it used to the only way we're
going to have a great future in America
is if we welcome and embrace immigrants
the dreamers and all of them because our
ultimate goal is to help the dreamers
but get a path to citizenship for all 11
million or however many undocumented
there are here
so when conservatives say the exact same
thing that Chuck Schumer just said it is
a racist and ridiculous conspiracy
theory
when Chuck Schumer says it it's a moral
and necessary process that we have to
speed up because Americans are not
having children
now I'm no expert I don't have an
advanced degree in political science I'm
not a U.S senator
but wouldn't another solution to this
problem instead of importing millions of
foreign Nationals each year in violation
of the law and the will of the American
people be perhaps instead to
stop enforcing National policies that
discourage Americans from having babies
couldn't couldn't we do that Schumer is
saying that our nation
which uh just coincidentally subsidizes
abortion discourages marriage celebrates
sexual dysfunction exalts contraception
forces women into the workplace
suppresses wages through Mass migration
suppresses religion and undermines the
family
is apparently not having enough kids
who to thunk it so strange I think I
might have some solutions to that
problem
but the libs don't want to fix that
problem
because the libs don't want Americans to
have more kids because the libs don't
like Americans and they don't like
America and they want to fundamentally
transform this country and they are well
on their way to doing just that you're
just not allowed to say it I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I just don't know why we're not having
enough kids why is it I mean all of our
policies are designed to discourage
people from having kids why won't we
have kids so strange my favorite comment
yesterday is from moose chuckle what a
name who says I honestly think Trump's
speech was the best one he's done
biggest complaint even of those who
support him
is this Brash nature and his mouth he
was energetic direct and focused all
without being a complete jerk yeah I
think that's true that was obviously the
strategy going into the speech I guess
I'm just in the minority
because I like Brash Trump that is that
is my favorite Trump
I like clear bold brash
takes no prisoners Trump
I like it when Trump is Trump
I get it that might not play well with
with I don't know moderates or centrists
or the Suburban people or whatever so
maybe Trump did what he had to do
I'm not knocking him I think this the
speech obviously was strategic
I just
my favorite Trump is the Trump who when
he is confronted in the debate by Megan
Kelly and she says you've said terrible
things about women you've called them
fat and ugly and all these terrible
things and he cuts her off and he says
only Rosie O'Donnell that's my favorite
Trump okay the Trump who just you can't
believe what he's saying it so breaks
the rules of our political status quo
but I might be in the minority Trump
might be doing the right thing he's
trying to protect his campaign so that
he can protect the country we've got to
protect our homes and our communities
that's why you got to check out ring
right now head on over to ring.com
collections slash offers with Christmas
right around the corner many of us are
going to be traveling to see our
families and loved ones soon
Thanksgiving is coming up you got a
whole lot of holidays okay you may find
yourself away from home more often than
not that is why I've decided to team up
with ring with ring security products
you can rest easy knowing that your home
and family are safe when you are not
there the ring doorbell notifies you
when guests or packages arrive Rings
indoor cameras let you keep an eye on
kids and pets while you're away ring
alarm will alert you of any motion
detection while the house is empty plus
if you add smart lighting around your
home you can turn lights on or off while
you're away Ring's home security
products don't just help keep your home
and family safe they make perfect gifts
for everyone on your list head on over
to ring.com
collections slash offers to find out how
you can live a little less stressed this
season with a ring of product that is
right for you that is ring.com
collections slash offers
getting real tough these days to figure
out what the difference is between a
conspiracy theory and the truth
the left-wing media have screamed at us
until they are blue in the face that the
great replacement is a horrible racist
anti-semitic all the isms kind of
conspiracy theory and then Chuck Schumer
comes out
and describes the great replacement
in precise terms and says it's a
wonderful thing and it is happening and
we need more of it
so what is it
it got even crazier I just noticed this
in a post from uh clown world today one
of my favorite social media accounts
which I looked it up for myself if you
go to the video from the world
government Summit it's a world
government summit video and it says are
we ready for a new world order and this
is from this year's the 2022 World
Government Summit here is just a little
clip of what they are discussing in the
video
your Excellency
are you ready for a new world order
I think uh Becky the pro the main
problem is uh if you think of the
technology goes on and on and on here's
how we're going to have the New World
Order I'm on the panel about the New
World Order asking are we ready for the
new world order at the world government
Summit to create a new world order and
yet on the video YouTube has put a
disclaimer YouTube has said the New
World Order is a conspiracy theory
the New World Order is a wild crazy
conspiracy theory
which hypothesizes a secretly emerging
totalitarian world government it's not
secretly emerging where I'm watching the
video of the summit that just took place
this year that uses the exact language
that you were telling me is a conspiracy
theory these Libs have got to get better
control over their messaging because out
of one side of their mouth they're
saying that their plans are a conspiracy
theory out of the other side of their
mouth they are actively campaigning for
it on the Open Stage
just a reminder
just a reminder
that when you hear that phrase
conspiracy theory assume that the person
who is using it if they're using it in
Earnest assume that they are not making
an argument in good faith that is just a
phrase to shut up opponents the phrase
didn't even appear in the English
language really until the middle of the
20th century didn't really take off
until the latter part of the 20th
century
it's it's a a phrase just like so many
left-wing phrases
that is designed not to convey some
truth but to deceive you to shut you up
it's it's the kind of phrasing that we
see out of political correctness
okay they put the disclaimer on the
official verified channel for the world
government Summit about the New World
Order speaking of the world order and
conspiracy theories
two days ago
a missile hit Poland
and I didn't cover it on the show
yesterday because
we were in the fog of war and I did not
believe the media reports about the
missile and I'm glad I didn't believe
them because my hunch was right the
missile hits Poland we were instantly
told this is a Russian missile Russia
has attacked a NATO member State this
triggers Article Five we need to send
the bombers over to Moscow now we're in
World War Three baby let's do it this
was the kind of talk that was egged on
by the bellicose president of Ukraine
the most puffed up man in the world by
the Western media Vladimir zielinski who
says this is a clear Act of Russian
aggression and escalation
today happened what we warned about a
long time ago this terror is not limited
to our national borders it has spread to
the territory of Moldova and today
Russian missiles hit Poland
today Russian missiles hit Poland okay
so at this point the whole chattering
class all of the propagandists in the
west they just gobble this stuff up I
did not because as I've said for many
months now I do not believe anything
that I hear about the war in Ukraine
I will do my own research I will
investigate it myself sometimes I'll
come up with an answer that I think is
credible very often though it's still
the fog of war and I'm still not quite
sure I don't believe the propaganda
coming out of the Kremlin
and I don't believe the propaganda
coming out of the West
I think it is it is what I say it is I
think it is all wartime propaganda and
not to be believed and I sure am glad
that I waited because when you started
to do a little bit more research on on
this once you get past the mainstream
media headlines once you get past
Vladimir zielinski's begging for World
War III
you would notice that the Pentagon did
not confirm that it was a Russian
missile
other Western governments would not
confirm that it's a Russian missile then
we find out yesterday
it was not a Russian missile maybe the
right the missile was made in Russia
let's not forget Ukraine has been part
of Russia for a lot of its history
but the missile was fired according to
all of the intelligence sources now and
even according to the media by Ukraine
by Ukraine
so when they said it was a Russian
missile we had all the clamors for war
here we go hit a NATO country Article
Five what's world war three baby then we
find out it was a Ukrainian missile oh
never mind
never mind that's okay Move Along
nothing to see here there was actually a
headline in the New York Times this is
amazing they admit after the fact okay
it wasn't a Russian missile but then
then the headline is this is not
Ukraine's fault
tensions ease over missile strike in
Poland NATO and polish officials said
that it was a Ukrainian missile that
crossed the border and killed two people
but that Russia bore the blame
wait what hold on
when it's a Russian missile Russia Bears
the blame when it's a Ukrainian missile
Russia Bears a blame
when it's a Russian missile we got to
get ready for world war three when it's
a Ukrainian missile that hits a NATO
country oh never mind no big deal
tensions ease all of a sudden why the
same number of people were killed
the same NATO territory was violated
why
and by the way by the way
there is another theory that actually
maybe it was a Russian missile but that
the governments in the west are
downplaying that because they don't want
to escalate tensions with Moscow I I
don't know I don't know
I tend to believe Putin for for all of
his sins has been pretty precise when it
comes to the special military operation
he's been pretty precise in a lot of his
political actions since he's he took
power 20 years ago
I tend to believe it is more likely that
the Pentagon and Western intelligence
and the New York Times
are finally admitting the truth I think
they're the second story that they're
going with now actually is more likely
to be true
and the citizen journalists who have
been reporting on this from the
beginning when the mainstream media were
getting it wrong that very likely it was
a Ukraine missile
but it's it's a story
to remind you do not believe the first
news that you read
this this was true during the Trump days
whenever a crazy headline you saw about
Trump just wait 24 hours okay because
it's probably what you're reading is
probably not the reality well the same
is certainly true in Ukraine the same is
certainly true of all wars
okay and there are a lot of people who
are all too eager
to be duped into a major major war
over Ukraine with a Ukrainian president
who is pleading with the West to start
World War III to go to strike Moscow
to plunge the world into a potentially
or a potentially nuclear conflict
over what over Ukraine which has a
thousand year long territorial dispute
with Russia
world wars as I've said from the
beginning
world wars have started over a lot less
over a lot less than
energy disputes in Russia over a lot
less than color Revolutions in Eastern
Europe over a lot less than a missile
flying into Poland world wars have
started with a lot less and people ought
to be very very careful okay we got to
protect ourselves one way to protect
yourself is to arm yourself with our
Second Amendment rights and to exercise
those rights another way to to protect
yourself is to caffeinate yourself make
sure that you're ready and raring to go
for a fight and one way to combine those
things Black Rifle coffee right now head
on over to blackrightfulcoffee.com use
code Knowles do you have a coffee lover
on your Christmas shopping list Black
Rifle has all the best Brewing gear
thermoses mugs and apparel designed for
folks who love country and coffee Black
Rifle sources the most exotic roasts
from around the globe all the coffee is
roasted right here in the U.S by
veteran-led teams of coffee experts
stuff your Christmas stockings with the
latest roasts from Amer America's coffee
we're 10 off with my code Knowles
kw-l-e-s better yet sign your Secret
Santa up for a coffee Club subscription
imagine the joy of a pre-scheduled
coffee delivery your favorite roasts
when you need them most it is the gift
that keeps on giving Black Rifle coffee
company is veteran founded and operated
they take pride in serving coffee and
culture to people who love America every
purchase you make with Black Rifle helps
support veteran and first responder
causes go to blackriflecoffee.com use
promo code Knolls for 10 off coffee
Coffee Gear apparel or when you sign up
for a new coffee Club subscription
that's black riflecoffee.com promo code
Knowles for 10 off Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
speaking of Foreign Affairs
the saddest
most pathetic clip I've seen from the
world stage in a very long time took
place yesterday when Justin Trudeau
the rumored bastard child of Fidel
Castro but listen that is a conspiracy
theory I'm I don't buy I actually don't
buy it
he just behaves like Fidel Castro's son
but the prime minister of America's top
hat Justin Trudeau
had an impromptu meeting at the G20 with
Chinese president for Life Xi Jinping
the power dynamics were pathetic
everything we discussed everything we
discussed has been leaked to the papers
that's not appropriate says she
and it's not the way the conversation
was conducted says she there's poor
Justin Trudeau like a deer in the
headlights
there was sincerity on your part Justin
he starts to walk away
[Music]
and Justin just total beta moves as well
you know we have a free exchange and
we're gonna she won't even look at him
let's create the condition let's create
the conditions first bye see ya just
walks away from him poor Trudeau
you can tell he's like shaking as he
walks away portrait he can't he's
wobbling he's so he feels so awkward
it's so pathetic big daddy she is
obviously the power player in this
Dynamic and poor little Justin Trudeau
is cowering and this is really sad for
us
because Canada is and always has been
America's Top Hat I I use that phrase
somewhat jokingly but Canada really is
just sort of an extension of America and
the broader kind of anglo-american
sphere of influence and we used to be
the top guys in the world stage it did
not used to be the case that the Chinese
could come up to the westerners and boss
us around and tell us what to do and
dress us down in public
that did not happen that does happen now
because we have lost leverage and Power
on the world stage we are in an era of
Western decline
and Chinese ascent and this didn't just
come about organically or accidentally
this was a policy just as we were
talking at the top of the show about
this strange situation we're in where
Americans aren't having children wow
it's so weird how did we get there oh
Whoopsie Daisy yes we need Mass
migration
no it didn't just happen Whoopsie Daisy
it happened intentionally because in
part of changes to our immigration laws
in the first place which depressed wages
and
and discourage people from having kids
but also all the laws on sex the
complete redefinition and abolition of
marriage
the abortion laws
the promotion of contraception
the
forcing of women into the workforce it's
always phrased as we're allowing women
into the workforce oh yes no women have
the opportunity to go make widgets for
Mr McGillicuddy down at the factory but
is that really how it works for most
women
I know a lot of women who would like to
stay home and raise their kids I know a
lot of women who would prefer that but
they can't do it because you can't raise
a family in America on one income
anymore they have to work
and then they have to pay a bunch of
money to some other woman to raise their
kids for them
it's it's
in in practice
our current labor laws
Force women into the workforce much more
than they give women the opportunity to
go work at the widget Factory okay and
that it didn't just happen accidentally
these are laws that we have passed to do
this sort of thing well it's the same
thing with national Decline and Chinese
Ascent Joe Biden was on the record I
think it was about 10 years ago he said
China's rising and that's a good thing
for everybody Rising title It's All
Ships it's good that we're encouraging
China
to grow and rise and become very very
strong
and this was I don't mean to just blame
Biden and the Democrats Biden's been
around forever so he Bears some
responsibility for it he was a big
promoter of this but it was the
Republicans too
it was both parties that encouraged
China to enter the World Trade
Organization we went really soft in our
trade deals with China
we encourage them to we let them steal
our IP we let them illegally devalue
their own currency we let them do all
sorts of things that gave them an
advantage over us and now we see the
consequences of that we and our little
vassals up there in Canada like Justin
Trudeau get dressed down very very sad
it is funny in that exchange I'm sort of
rooting for she you know the
and and Justin Trudeau I actually kind
of get a kick out of she dressing him
down but it's sad it's sad for our
civilization and it shows our relative
status in the world now speaking of
world leaders there is a shocking new
poll out this is from The Economist and
yougov it shows Ron DeSantis
not just gaming on Trump not even just
tied with Trump he's way up on Donald
Trump the poll asks if you had to choose
who would you rather see as the
Republican nominee for president 2024
51 percent chose DeSantis 33 percent
chose Trump 17 are not sure that means
Ron DeSantis right now in this poll is
18 points up on Trump
polls generally mean nothing primary
polls this far out and National primary
polls also don't really mean very much
because the primaries are conducted in
States
and if DeSantis gets in he won't be the
only one to get in I bet there will be a
lot of other candidates who get in and
so you'll see a big splitting of the
vote and it could be the case that that
Donald Trump then just gets a plurality
and this is what happened in 2016. he
didn't have the majority of the vote in
the Estates but he had the plurality and
the other guys stayed in the race a long
time and Donald Trump got the nomination
all of that might happen
but this should worry Trump
that he is falling this far behind
this early on
I I assume this is why Trump declared
early
I think this is why Trump's speech was
relatively restrained as he wanted to
show that he can he can be Trump without
the downsides he can be what their
billing to Santa says but this is
leading to a GOP Civil War whether we
want to admit it or not Ron DeSantis was
just asked about it here's his answer
look I think we we just we just finished
this election okay people just need to
chill out a little bit on some of this
stuff I mean seriously we just ran an
election
we have this Georgia runoff coming which
is very important for Republicans to win
that Georgia runoff I mean I know around
the country Florida was kind of the the
biggest bright spot it was not so bright
in many other parts of the country it
was a it was a it was a substandard
performance given the Dynamics that are
at play so hopefully we'll be able to be
able to do that but I think what people
like me who've been given the
opportunity to continue is okay uh let's
do something with that and the reason
why we want historic Victory is at the
end of the day we LED we delivered and
we had your back when you needed us that
that is why we won big
DeSantis goes on we don't have the clip
he goes on to say and so we're going to
continue to deliver we're not going to
look back
I think that's very very significant so
he gives a good answer here he doesn't
talk about Trump specifically but this
is all about Trump he says look people
like me who have been given the
opportunity to continue right unlike
Trump who only got one term me I got
reelected so here's what we're going to
do and I'm not going to look back
Trump's speech was all looking back look
at what I did look at what I did look
we're not looking back we're looking
forward so he is tailoring all of his
answers here they're in a somewhat
veiled way
but nevertheless these are barbs back at
Trump trump started the fight DeSantis
is throwing these Jabs not openly yet
but folks we're two years out and it's
already getting this testy between Trump
and DeSantis
and what I urge people and I I have
urged my fellow conservative pundits
public figures politicians I've
suggested to people hey we have
primaries for a reason let this thing
play out you don't need to just dig your
heels in and be the most hardcore I'm
DeSantis or die or I'm Trump or die or
I'm I don't know Tim Scott or die I
don't know how many of those people
there are but you you know we're very
we're very early we we as a party have a
primary process for a reason it's okay
you don't need to pretend that Trump
wasn't the best conservative president
of your lifetime you know he was you
know he was you don't need to pretend
that you hate Trump you probably love
Trump he's a very lovable guy likewise
you don't need to pretend that DeSantis
hasn't done a good job in Florida he's
done a great job in Florida he's a good
candidate there's no question about that
it's okay guys it's all right people
don't like
uncertainty it gives them anxiety and
they don't like it and so people just
want to rush to a conclusion well life
is about cultivating patience and
resignation in large part these are
virtues okay and you've got you've got
to let things play out in their due time
all right I know but it's tough because
there's a lot of political pressure
these days there's there's a lot of
people trying to attack you for your
views that's why you probably want to
anonymize your data online that's why
you need expressvpn right now head on
over to expressvpn.com Knowles profiling
surveillance data harvesting there are a
lot of things that I do not like about
tech Giants but there's only so much
that I can do I don't have 44 billion
dollars to go buying up Twitter yet yet
we just need a few more subscriptions
then we can do it good news is right now
you don't have to be a billionaire to
take a stand for less than seven bucks
per month you can join me and fight back
against big Tech by using Express VPN
big tech companies make their money by
tracking your online activity your
searches your video history everything
that you click on they sell those data
to advertisers who Target you expressvpn
helps you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your IP address so
they can't match any activity back to
you I love expressvpn I use it on all my
devices to make it much more difficult
for big tech companies to exploit my
data for their own profits super easy to
use just tap one button on your phone or
computer and you are free to roam the
internet free from big tax prying eyes
if you don't like big Tech tracking you
and selling your personal data for
profit fight back by using expressvpn
that's expressvpn.com Knowles right now
you'll get three extra months of
expressvpn for free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles
DeSantis throwing some Digs at Trump
Trump throwing some Digs at DeSantis
speaking of burns
uh Jay Leno has just suffered very
serious Burns kind of a hard segue but
it relates very broadly to what we're
talking about here uh Jay Leno as a lot
of people know loves cars he loves
working on his own cars he was working
on one of his cars and he got gasoline
sprayed onto his face and then there was
a spark and his face caught on fire I
mean it just sounds absolutely awful uh
he was rushed to the hospital he could
have died
easily easily could have died Dr Peter
Grossman who's a board-certified plastic
surgeon in La told reporters that Leno
suffered quote significant Burns to his
face and hands and required a surgical
excision and grafting procedure uh Leno
then told TMZ
that his friend Dave who was in the
garage with him at the time was able to
smother the Flames otherwise it easily
could have killed him and then the
doctor said
now this is just like a couple of days
later that Leno was in good spirits and
was even helping with the other patients
and giving children cookies
said quote we're very happy to have him
as part of our team
so this guy who just gets his face and
hands burnt off and a couple of days
later he's out cracking jokes having a
fun time in the hospital giving kids
cookies
a lot of people are asking how can he do
this people probably aren't that
surprised because when you think of Jay
Leno you just think of this very buoyant
guy just like
he was always just kind of happy he's
not one of these angry comedians right
he's very funny and delightful
a great lesson here
is is on how good it is to cultivate
buoyancy
okay how good it is to
not only be resilient in the sense that
you're really tough and you can
withstand troubles but to be buoyant
that when that when circumstances get
you down and try to smother you drown
you in the water you just pop right back
up
buoyancy is really really important and
people very often just have the opposite
they'll they'll sink to the bottom even
if they're taking a nice swim in the
Caribbean Ocean you know even if even if
they're in broadly happy circumstances
they'll still find some terrible thing
some negative discomfort to to obsess
about
you don't want to do that people have
this fantasy which is you know I'm
things are tough right now but once I
get past this then I'll be happy uh you
know it's a tough week at work but once
I get past this week at work then then
I'll be happy
um having a hard time you know with my
family but once once this one thing
changes six months from now then I'll be
happy ah you know the house needs work
oh it's so annoying I got a leak in my
ceiling once we fix that leak though
then I'll be happy and
the people who think that way are never
happy that's the secret because there's
always going to be some other thing
and there's always going to be some
circumstance that is imperfect because
we live in a fallen world
so it is
I think your duty but it's certainly
greatly to your benefit to cultivate
that kind of buoyancy now
circumstances are sort of morally
neutral okay suffering is not a an
immoral thing
so you can respond to suffering in a in
a good moral edifying sanctifying way or
you can respond to it in a degrading and
and
dissatifying way I hate that word
because it's a silly word but you can in
a destructive way in a way that is
really not going to be good for you okay
suffering is just part of the world
and so you'll notice
the people who
the people who can have their face burnt
off and still be happy and buoyant and
able to get by the next day
they're the people who don't sweat the
small stuff either you know it's a it's
not a fact of circumstance it's a fact
of their own character and I think it's
on all of us to cultivate that
sometimes people will say you see this
in politics they'll say we just we just
need to do X Y and Z and then we'll
finally achieve a good country that's
what we need to achieve a good country
a country is not a thing to achieve
a country is a place to inhabit okay
it's not we're going to get there this
has a progressives talk we're gonna get
there we're not there yet but we're
gonna get there where we achieve this
good country we're already there when
we're in the country okay we are here
and
every single moment of the day
we have the option to to pursue good and
avoid evil or to pursue evil and avoid
good in all of our little decisions
that's how you have a good country okay
is you just do the right thing
consistently and you cultivate that
habit because virtue is a habit and then
you have a good country
it's not some distant thing six months
from now then we're gonna have a good
country you can do it right now
a lot of that involves cultivating a
spirit of resignation speaking of the
spirit of resignation
Mitch McConnell will be re-elected
uh Republican majority Republican
minority leader in the Senate that is
going to happen there was a challenge
from Rick Scott Rick Scott a more
conservative senator from Florida
he challenged McConnell
they held a vote it was it was a secret
ballot because none of the Senators want
to get on cocaine Mitch's bad side
because he's just going to turn out like
Tony Montana you know and pull that
automatic weapon say hello to my little
right so it was a secret ballot Rick
Scott Pride away about 10 votes
McConnell gets reelected
and he he told us that this would happen
he said I have the votes I will be
elected the only issue is whether we do
it sooner or later now I don't hate
Mitch McConnell in the way that a lot of
conservatives do because McConnell held
firm on the judges when Scalia died and
McConnell is in large part the reason
why we got to overrule Roe v Wade and
why Trump probably one of the main
reasons Trump got elected to replace
Scalia and then why
we got that big victory in Dove so
I like McConnell but the man is not a
hard-line rock ribbed conservative Chuck
Schumer now the Senate Majority Leader
again is already talking about sitting
down with McConnell and trying to kill
off the Maga movement I am going to say
to the Republicans in the Senate who are
not the Maga Republicans stop letting
them lead your party work with us to get
things done and I intend to sit down
with Mitch McConnell and express that
and I think you've been saying that what
are you asking for it just quickly when
are you gonna you're sitting down in
Mitch McConnell this week no I'm gonna I
intend I've said this yesterday and the
day before too I intend to sit down with
him and say how can we we should be
working together you're not going to get
the extremists in your party to work
with anybody but the rest of us can work
together and get them some real things
done for the American people
so thankfully CNN clarified here and
said wait when are you sitting down with
Mitch McConnell and he said no I intend
to so it's not like they have a meeting
on the books but I'm sure McConnell will
be more than open to these
this Overture from Schumer
McConnell hates the Maga wing of the
party there's no question about that
the GOP establishment in Washington DC
hates the Maga wing of the party
and
this is why
just as we talk about healthy skepticism
when we hear reports out of the war in
Ukraine we need healthy skepticism when
we hear reports out of why the
Republicans did or did not perform in
the midterms
the people who hate Donald Trump and the
Maga movement
are going to be much more inclined to
blame the disappointing performance on
during the midterms on Trump and the
Maga movement
almost to a man the people who are
blaming this thing on Trump didn't like
Trump to begin with and don't like the
Maga movement
now if you talk to the mega movement
people and the people who like Donald
Trump
they're going to be much more inclined
to blame
the upending of our voting rules for
what happened on Tuesday
they're going to say yeah we had a red
wave in Florida and maybe you can say
that's only because of DeSantis but how
do you explain the Red Wave in Texas how
do you explain the Red Wave in Ohio how
do you explain the difference between
Florida Texas and Ohio and Arizona and
Nevada
well the difference there is that
Florida Texas and Ohio had tightened up
their voting rules and they didn't even
tighten them up all that much but they
tightened them up a little bit after
2020. Arizona and Nevada did not there
were a whole lot of shenanigans that we
saw in Arizona and Nevada and surprise
surprise the Republicans lose
so if you look at it from that Vantage
which I think is much more persuasive
then the question is not over candidate
quality or those crazy Maga candidates
JD Vance was a crazy Mega candidate he
won just fine
wasn't just oh you know it's Blake
Masters and Carrie like they're crazy
Maga candidates there it would seem that
the more decisive Factor
was the election
laws
that the changing to the way that we
conduct the elections which give a huge
benefit to the Democrats the majority of
votes coming in early as a result of
things like ballot harvesting right
that's obviously going to favor
Democrats Republicans don't have a
ballot harvesting
organization we just don't have it at
all Democrats have had them for decades
maybe that's
maybe that's really what's going on here
I just would urge caution as when you
read the news about Ukraine urge caution
and and maybe notice every now and again
that the people who are so insistent
this is exactly what happened very often
it's the people who got all their
predictions wrong about the elections
but then the next day they're going to
go on air and tell you this is exactly
what happened who have no epistemic
humility whatsoever here they're they're
going to say
that just coincidentally
what happened in my analysis of the
elections what happened is
every single thing to confirm my own
priors yeah okay I'm a little skeptical
of that I don't think so I don't think
that we should accept the establishment
line maybe we don't even necessarily
accept the the mega line of argument at
face value maybe we look into these
things for ourselves and recognize it's
a complex process there's a lot at play
and there are a lot of forces who are
fighting a long simmering Civil War that
actually has nothing to do with the
midterms and it's been going on for a
very very long time have you watched the
exclusive three-part series Dr Jordan B
Peterson's on marriage yet because I
would strongly recommend it
I I think every single day I am truly
blessed by God I was thinking this just
last night as I was going to bed I am so
so blessed to have my wonderful wife
sweet little Elisa and my two sweet
little kids and it's just truly it a I
can't even articulate what that feels
like
with marriage rates at an all-time low
in the United States and a birth rate
that is continuing to fall
not everyone gets that sort of joy that
that and and people should many more
people should have that sort of Joy
everyone needs to watch this show
especially young people statistics are
showing that younger people are getting
married much later in life and less
frequently too now our audience is not
filled with Peter Pan's but just in case
there are a few stragglers who are late
to the marriage and family party
consider this a pleasant little kick in
the teeth stop being so self-centered
for those of you married folks who have
like time and work and outside forces
get in the way
Jordan will also show you how to
navigate through those moments and get
back to that romantic fun adventure you
had at the beginning daily wire Plus
members can catch all three episodes of
Jordan Peterson's on marriage today if
you're not a member go to dailywire.com
Knowles to join today remember your
membership really helps us to prevent
the total collapse of society as we know
it if the shows were not incentive
enough that I hope pushes you across the
finish line
there are plenty of arguments about the
role of Mega and Trump going into the
future there's one really weak argument
though that I keep hearing and actually
I heard it from a guy that I like a lot
Nick Mulvaney
was a former well I think it was Chief
of Staff to Donald Trump at least acting
chief of staff and so he was a Maga guy
he supported Trump he was with him but
he says that Trump is probably the one
guy
who could lose in 2024.
you think this is good for the
Republican party no I I don't because I
think he's the only Republican who could
lose
um if he run if he wins in 2024 now he's
a candidate he is the likely Republican
nominee can he be beaten Head to Head by
Ron DeSantis or Tim Scott sure but it's
not going to be a head-to-head race
there'll be five or six other people in
the race and he'll get the 35 percent
that really support him and under the
winner take all primary system he'll be
the nominee
um but that means the 2024 race is not
about Joe Biden or whatever Democrat is
on the on the ticket not about inflation
not about world events not about
abortion it'll be about Donald Trump the
same thing we saw in 2020. no one voted
for Joe Biden everybody voted for or
against Donald Trump it was a referendum
on him and that's what we're hurtling
towards in 2024 and I don't see the
outcome being any different two years
from now than it was two years ago
so I like Mick Mulvaney I don't think
the guy's a squish I think a lot of his
analysis is quite good especially well I
actually had given the same analysis
earlier in the show I think his analysis
of the way the primaries shake out is
very very good as well if you look at
2016 had Rubio dropped out earlier Ted
Cruz would have been the GOP nominee
it's just it's just the way the
primaries work but because he stayed in
it split that anti-trump vote and so
Donald Trump gets the plurality
plurality plurality eventually he's the
nominee so I think all of that's true
where I think Mulvaney though is wrong
and frankly naive
is the idea that Donald Trump is the
only Republican who could lose in 2024.
I have almost the exact opposite take
I I sort of think that it's virtually
impossible for a republican to win in
2024. I I took a little look at the
election map
okay the Electoral College map here and
I went through
all of the states that Republicans could
win and I was very generous on the
toss-up States okay I said that
Republicans get Florida I said
Republicans get Texas sure I said
Republicans get Ohio I said Republicans
get Wisconsin that's far from certain
but I said let's say Republicans get
Wisconsin I said Republicans get North
Carolina far from certain probably
unlikely but okay let's throw that there
too I said Republicans get Nevada very
far from certain I'm very skeptical the
Republicans will get Nevada but okay
let's say Republicans get Nevada okay
even still
I gave the Democrats Michigan
gave the Democrats Colorado I think is
quite clear at this point even still
with all of that being so generous to
what the Republicans could get
without Arizona the Republicans lose
and Arizona has real problems with the
elections though those Maricopa
voting machines just they just don't
seem to work all that well Whoopsie
Daisy
the people conducting the elections in
Arizona well the the top official to
conduct elections in this past cycle was
Katie Hobbs who was the Democrat who was
running for governor and then
coincidentally won but even you look at
the Maricopa County officials there was
a uh a rejoinder to the questioning on
the right of the the Maricopa elections
and people pointed out they said well
you know the Maricopa County officials
conducting the elections they're
actually Republicans yeah they're
Republican mostly Republicans sort of
except that they hate Donald Trump
they're never Trump Republicans they go
on left-wing news outlets they have been
going on for a very long time lambasting
Donald Trump and the trumpian candidates
and anyone who raises any questions
about the election procedures then you
look at the election laws in Arizona
they heavily favor Democrats and so
I'm highly skeptical that if we can't
tune up these laws that any Republican
could possibly win but the idea that oh
it's only Donald Trump so only Donald
Trump the people give me a break
part of the reason that the other
candidates look shiny right now is
because the national apparatus has not
attacked them yet attacked them to some
degree DeSantis has taken plenty of
slings and arrows
but nowhere near the kind of slings and
arrows that we've seen from Trump it's
not desantis's fault DeSantis hasn't run
a national campaign yet
and that's what happens and very often
what will happen is the media will prop
up certain Republican candidates during
the primary campaign only to try to
clobber them in the General in fact
that's exactly what happened with Donald
Trump the media encouraged Donald Trump
they celebrated Trump because they
thought he'd be the easiest to beat in
the general election
then it turned out Trump beats Hillary
the idea I'm not I am not saying with
certainty
the Trump is the best candidate in 2024
I'm far from saying that
but he is far from the worst candidate
Donald Trump helped put together a
coalition
that was different and better
than the GOP establishment coalition
then the Mitt Romney for listen 47
percent of Americans are just
freeloading poor people that remember
that remember that comment
listen we're just going to cut all we're
just going to cut taxes and Outsource
all of your jobs and open up the borders
remember remember that Republican Party
I know I think the Trump movement
inspires far greater support
than uh and the other stuff and yes he's
gotten the attacks sure he's been in the
game for six seven years now
but the next guy's gonna get that too I
remember during the primaries in 2016
2015. I was sitting in uh in Los Angeles
at a bar and uh one of the staff members
comes over
and uh this guy was obviously Hispanic I
didn't know if he was legal or illegal
had a very thick accent and uh didn't
ask him and and he's looking and we're
watching the debates and he's kind of
shaking his head at the candidate so I
forget who was on maybe it was I don't
know Ted Cruz I said oh you don't like
Ted Cruz he goes no he's not my guy
I said who do you like
you like uh
Hillary because no I don't like Hillary
oh okay but you like Rubio nah I don't
like Rubio you go I go through all the
candidates I finally get down to the
last one I said wait
Who Who Are You supporting Trump my man
Trump and I
I
just
have found again and again
it's not the fancy people at the fancy
DC cocktail parties and the big think
tanks at the fancy lunches or wherever
it's ordinary people working ordinary
jobs that you don't hear about on TV
those are the people who flock to Trump
who did not like other candidates could
a Rhonda Santos win over those people
yeah sure maybe I don't know we'll see
if when they run a national campaign but
we know that Trump got them and this
idea that he's always uniquely
off-putting to people I I don't buy that
for one second
John McCain was uniquely off-putting the
people he lost Mitt Romney was uniquely
off-putting to people he lost I guess
not uniquely he just kind of ordinarily
off-putting to people
Donald Trump won those guys lost Donald
Trump one okay so don't tell me about
who who is guaranteed to lose
very very naive now speaking of maps
speaking of the election map speaking of
diagrams
of all the political rhetoric that we
have heard and analyzed in recent days
and weeks
I think I've just discovered the
absolute tippy top of the Heap the creme
de La Creme this would be our vice
president Kamala Harris giving a
discourse on Venn diagrams
remember Venn diagrams those three
circles right and then let's just see
where they overlap you will not be
surprised because I have constructed a
Venn diagram on this remember those
three circles how they overlap I love
Venn diagrams so I just do whenever
you're dealing with conflict pull out a
Venn diagram right and so you know this
recircles and so I so I asked my team
right they're freaking out right now he
sees the Venn diagram of it all he sees
that there are those circles and maybe
people seem that they're a little
different they live in different parts
of the country they may be different age
or different race but that area in the
middle that overlap but I asked my team
to do a Venn diagram of where these
attacks are happening so voting rights
women's Reproductive Rights lgbtq rights
and of course there was a huge
intersection you know I asked my team to
do a Venn diagram for me of where we are
seeing attacks and who are the attacks
against and the similarity and when you
look at a diagram of the uh just a Venn
diagram in that regard it tells a real
Tale
this is the caliber of intellect leading
our country
a third grade caliber of intellect this
is I almost wonder when I watch that
clip did Kamala Harris just learn what a
Venn diagram is did she or I don't know
what's better that she just learned what
a Venn diagram is or that her education
never progressed past the third grade
because connoll Harris I guess has a law
degree
but
you know this is typical now of our
education structure we flatter ourselves
we say oh we're the most educated
generation ever oh yes Americans have
more degrees than ever right but we're
we have more degrees but we are much
less educated because those degrees
don't mean anything anymore because all
the standards have been dramatically
lowered for various reasons of national
policy and the decay of these
institutions the standards are much
lower now such that you could have a not
only a bachelor's degree but a law
degree
and this is the height of your political
thinking not exactly metternique okay
we're not talking about tally Rand over
here all right this is where we are and
do not think for one second that that
woman cannot become president
I just I just want to encourage people
to expand their political imaginations I
think I guess that's sort of the theme
of this show
don't believe what the fact Checkers
tell you about the crazy conspiracy
theories don't believe what the
propagandists tell you about the fog of
War
trying to clear up the fog of War don't
believe what the pundits with their own
agendas tell you about oh Trump can't
win or this this person's the only
person who can win
I would not believe any of that stuff
okay
don't believe them when they tell you
Kamala Harris can't become President
John Federman is about to become a U.S
senator all right it said that they said
that no one would elect a guy who can't
speak they did they said no one would
elect Trump they did that woman could be
your next president all right that's not
enough to motivate you to get out and
help the Republicans win I I don't know
what will there are so many questions
specifically regarding women actually in
this country right now and probably
the question that's giving me the most
trouble the question that's keeping me
awake at night is
why do attractive women
find
Pete Davidson lovable
why why are good-looking successful put
together women why are they drawn like a
moth to a flame to Skeet to this sort of
meth addict looking sort of strange odd
creepy guy why why
we're going to find out I will be
hosting a panel right now in the member
block
of women
of good-looking normal women from around
the country to explain to me the appeal
of ski Davidson the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]